what's happening you bad [__]
wednesday january 27th
we're coming out the box strong is dead
listen the super bowl is the big game
and it's in two weeks
but after that you know what the big
game is valentine's day it's time to get
that [__] out of [__] quarantine
i know people haven't gotten laid in a
[__] year but first you got to trim
it up a little bit
you got a [__] d big you got to put
some pink paint on the helmet
it's all [__] up it's like a spooky
[__] house
but what you need to do is let my
friends at manscape
treat your [__] package like the gift
that it is and give your ladies
something to unwrap
a big [__] beautiful [__] you
understand me
trimming your balls used to be scary but
with manscape
i'm an artist now and you know my balls
are [__] famous
it's nice and easy right here you just
press that button
and there you go the lawnmower 3.0 the
best trimmer known to [__] man
you could use it anywhere it goes at the
knicks
nooks and crannies places that you gotta
hear
that you don't even [__] know but it
starts right now today
you got to go to manscape.com press and
code joey
what they do is they got a tremendous
package that i [__] preach to
everybody
it comes with the lawnmower 3.0 the best
trimmer knows
to mankind they throw in the crop
preserver plus they throw in these
little packages i'm all out of them
the ball wipes you put them in your
wallet just in case you want to give
somebody a sniff on the on the move
and now manscape has a cologne so you
put some on your neck
some on your nut sack listen you're
gonna be ready for valentine's
day let manscape help you out get 20
off and free shipping at manscape.com
joey that's 20 off with free shipping at
manscape.com
joe it's time to make february 13th
international trim your ball sack
[__] day by manscape
go to manscape.com joey
and get your party started now that you
got your balls clean for valentine's day
now you got to show up with a dick that
works that's why uncle joey comes in
again
the joint is brought to you by blue chew
listen it's winter
things are tough all over but if you pop
a [__] blue chew
i can tell you one thing is going to be
looking up your [__] [__]
that [__] [__] helmet that eyeball is
gonna be [__] ginormous
she's not gonna know what to do when you
take that [__] dick out
first of all the manscape's gonna trim
it and then blue chew's gonna help you
get that [__] dick
you're gonna listen that one-eyed
soldier is the stimulus check
all these freaks are waiting for nobody
wants to show up with a lip think
even if your dick works fully you might
as well go in there with the big
you want to have the a rambo dick you
understand me
right with bows and arrows explosives
that's what you're giving at that's what
you get with blue chew
same fda improve active ingredients as
viagra and cialis
what are you gonna do what are your
options buying it at some [__] liquor
store
blue chew is [__] science blue chew
is prescribed online
by licensed physicians so you don't
gotta go to the doctor's office
and get the malloy eye and then [__]
wait online at the [__] pharmacy
and it ships to your door just in a
discreet package nobody knows
it's not like an envelope with a big
pink dick on it and your [__] mailman
knows you got [__] soft dick no no no
blue chew is also cheaper than a
pharmacy and you can take them any time
day or night even on a full stomach now
right now today
wednesday the 27th they got a special
offer so you can start slinging dick
today
and by the 14th you'll be back up the
[__] part
visit bluetooth.com that's blue b-l-u-e
chew dot-com and get your first shipment
free
troy what are you talking about get your
first shipment for free all you gotta do
is pay the five dollar shipping
and again that's blue blue like the
color of the face when you put your dick
in a [__] monkey
and it's gonna be popping off you
understand me that's what happens when
you show up at bluetooth dogs
bluetooth.com use code joey
j-o-e-y and we thank them for continuing
to sponsor
uncle joey's joint let's get this
[__] show started
we got manscaped and we got blue chew
you cannot go
look wrong it is what's happening
check one two welcome to uncle joey's
[Music]
joy
what's happening you bad [__]
it's wednesday
january whatever the [__] it is i don't
even know anymore i'm so sick of the
[__] date
i just tell say a date to remind myself
what [__] day it is what's happening
you bad [__]
everything's good uh the stitches are
out so with three quarters there
i got a little [__] stitch story for
you so i [__]
you know i'm off i'm fine all weekend
i'm fine i do my exercise i go to pt
monday morning i gotta go to pt and i
gotta get my stitches taken out it was
the other way around though on monday
morning how to go get my stitches taken
out
and then go to pt i'll tell you when i
woke up monday morning i knew it
like sometimes you wake up and you're
like having one of those days now
i've been sleeping [__] phenomenal
lately the best sleep i've been getting
the last two years
has been since i've gotten this surgery
downstairs i've had a couple rough
nights like the beginning was a couple
rough nights
i didn't know how to time the medication
the pain [__] like that
but the last week i've been getting some
[__] good sleep
a couple [__] power naps you know
[__] like that but
i get up monday morning and i'm just not
feeling it
i can't call the doctor and tell them i
can't go down and take the stitches
i'm just beside myself with fear i don't
know why
you know me it comes out of nowhere
anxiety with me comes out of nowhere
i'm feeling [__] crazy a little who
bots i take a shower
i eat breakfast i put my daughter in the
car you know the whole [__] thing she
goes to school
and then me and my wife head there i get
in the car
like hold on one second to my wife she
goes why i go
this anxiety or whatever the [__] i'm
going through is making me want to go to
the bathroom
she goes what do you want to do do you
want to go to the bathroom
and be a couple minutes late i go you
know what it's right there on the tip
i think i can hold it in i'll be fine
i'm gonna be fine so i get down to the
doctor's office
you know for some reason guys i get
myself all worked up we all do but i get
myself
super worked up when it comes to [__]
needles
i go upstairs i check in you know you
have to [__] text
and then they [__] tell you when to
come upstairs
and then she calls me instead she goes
i come upstairs as soon as i walk in i'm
just not feeling it
i'm [__] hot you know i got a hooded
sweatshirt on
and a sweatshirt it's cold out and it's
layers so i got a t-shirt a hooded
sweatshirt a sweatshirt
and i heard the sweatshirt on top of
that i [__]
i talked to the guy one of the guy
listens to the podcast i talk to him
i say hello i say hello to girls i sit
down he goes the doctor will be with you
in a couple of minutes i go listen
how much of these staples going to hurt
get taken out now i ain't got like 10
staples
i got like a [__] row of [__]
so whatever it's going to be i'm already
getting anxiety just telling you
[__] the story
whatever it's going to be it's going to
be a couple [__] minutes so
i asked the guy and the guy goes it
won't hurt especially since you had him
in
for two weeks it'll be a little easier
to take him out
he goes the doctor's gonna come in and
talk to you for a few minutes
and then we'll pull them out i go fine
i'm just sitting in the regular chair
they take my blood pressure it's okay
everything's fine my oxygen levels are
fine
my pulse is on the money ooh tremendous
all of a sudden i'm sitting there i'm
just working myself up
working myself up and finally a doctor
comes in i look at him and go
what's going on doc and he's like let me
look at the stitches he goes oh the
swelling went down you look good
let me see you move it around and he
looks up at me goes what's the matter
with you and i go doc i'm just not
feeling it
i think i'm gonna pass out he goes your
skin color is as white as the mask
my skin color just went white and i
started [__] sweating right
so i go can you get me some water he
goes ah i know you had a hard time with
the surgery in the beginning but you did
fine i'll be fine let me just drink the
water
and i start drinking the [__] water
and uh
oh my god this is terrible i just get
this feeling that i'm gonna pass out and
everything's spinning in fact when he
got up there was two of them
like when he came in there was one of
them when he got up
there was two of them i'm like oh i'm
gonna [__] faint
so i gotta do what i usually do i just
gotta take the bull by the horns
he goes uh the water's gonna come in and
then get on the
the big table we'll pop it up for you
laid back
and he'll take the [__] stitches out
right so
i put my little santana on that's my
music for needles and [__]
and i laid back and he's taking the
[__] thing he starts taking them out
guys
and it's just like little needles but
everyone
is just impacting me like everyone it's
like little acupuncture needles days
[__]
guys between us it doesn't hurt at all
like a normal person with good joy what
is wrong with you because but because
it's me
i'm like yeah and i got the [__]
santana on
and i'm i i into myself and i
look at the guy the guy looks at me goes
how we doing and he goes you're sweating
and i go i know i'm sweating i'm [__]
dying here he goes if it makes you feel
better
i can't go over bridges he goes i can't
go into staten island i can't go into
new york
i can't go into jersey i'm stuck because
i have a fear of bridges so i'm like
holy [__]
but when somebody tells you their
card it makes you feel a lot better you
know what i'm saying
so calm it down a little bit it didn't
calm me down all the way
it just calmed me down a little bit and
i'm like
oof oof and he's pulling them out and
he's hitting the tin with him
because they're going to the tent and
i'm ding ding
dink and to myself i'm like one of these
[__] dinks gonna stop
one of these things gonna end i didn't
look at my leg one time
i just kept looking away and [__] and
[__] i had my earphones on and i'm
like and i'm still here in the dinks
and i'm like one of these things gonna
[__] start and finally
i felt them by my knee and he goes
you're done mr diaz
and he goes how you feeling he goes you
don't look good i go i don't look good
i don't feel good let me just finish my
water and i'm drinking my [__] water
he goes this is what we're gonna do
i want you to sit here for about 10
minutes you're not going to go anywhere
i don't want you to get up you have
nowhere to go
i call physical therapy tom you're going
to be late just sit here for about 10
minutes
and wait for this to come down and then
we'll let you leave is that okay with
him i go
yeah i'll be i'll be okay in 10 minutes
he's not out of the room one minute
and i feel a missile from here just come
like an adrenaline missile
just come down and it's just a little
explosion fart like a boop
but dog it was right there that [__] i
had to take when i got in the car
my wife was in my [__] ready to get
served
i could hear it percolating it was
percolating in my ass
but i'm dying right i'm half [__]
dying like i'm like oh
oh but it was between fainting even
harder was [__]
dog i said i'm not gonna faint and [__]
my pants that's definitely not gonna
happen
out of somewhere i just got the strength
i just opened my eyes
i picked my leg over i threw it over the
[__] table and i ain't gonna
they looked at me like what are you
doing up i go dog
i gotta go to the bathroom and i think
out of the three of them the doctor the
nurse
and the male nurse i think the male
nurse was like hurry up
because i he knew he knew was an
adrenaline it was a pure adrenaline [__]
i [__] flew in that bathroom and 22
chunks of [__] just came flying out like
i was bombing the country with [__]
i had a flush like three times it
smelled so bad in that [__] bathroom
i had to open the door thank god there
was nobody in the waiting room
so i go back and they're like are you
okay and i'm like yeah i'm okay now
they thought like i'm probably vomiting
or something they didn't know it was the
quickest [__] of my life
it just flew out i think it was one wipe
and i was done
so when i went back to sit down i went
to put my sneakers on the guy cause like
no no no no
you're still pale i'm trying to get the
[__] out of there before the
[__] comes out of that bathroom and it
starts reeking all over that [__]
office
i left like a little open i let the
front fan but it was out where the
patients were sitting
so there was only like two patients back
then they were both against the wall
so i tried to put my sneakers on or try
to get ready i had to put my sweatshirt
on
and i heard the sweatshirt back on and
also i'm talking to the doctor he's
telling me but
he's got to give me another prescription
for therapy and another prescription for
some [__] pills for
anti-inflammatory and dog i'm standing
in the hallway
and all of a sudden i could actually
smell my [__]
from 10 minutes early and it's [__]
thick
it's [__] thicker than debt i [__]
took those prescriptions
and before any of those women in that
front office could smell it
i poor ass out of that [__] office
and i ran to the [__] i thought my
wife would go let's get out of here
before they figure out i destroyed that
[__] bathroom
it was embarrassing as [__] but
somebody's got to do it
that's the wednesday morning [__] story
i wanted to lay on you
you know we always lay some type of [__]
story on you there was one last week
because they give me these pills at 7 30
they got to take them i think i got four
left
they're like two to to break you know
because all the drugs you're eating
make your stomach get all full and [__]
like that so this
you know i don't know what it's called
the distance yeah what's it called
constipation from the pills this missile
shoots right through the constipation
who gives the [__] i figured we'd open
up with a little cha cha just to break
the ice you know what i'm saying
it's wednesday we gotta go who's gonna
be uptight did you get your vaccine yet
no who gives a [__]
you're still gonna die who gives a [__]
anyway
eventually everybody now with the
[__] vaccine
it's not enough the school teachers
ain't getting them right
it never [__] ends it never [__]
ends
at least we got ourselves we got our
lives our minds
and our own hearts and stories i got an
email
on patreon the other day that was pretty
interesting and we'll discuss it it was
uh
how do you know did you ever feel uh
karma being served
he goes because right now i'm going
through a bad streak and
i ran wild for years like you did i want
to know if you ever felt
karma while i was being served
and the question took me back for a
second i'm like [__]
yeah you know i was on a i went on a
roll
you know jerk-off-wise
from the time my mother died to the time
i got arrested
when i got arrested that was karma being
served
and then son and i knew it i knew it
when i was singing that jail cell
that this is for all the sins i did blah
blah blah
when i ended up going to prison and i
got sentenced to prison
i made a constant effort while i was in
there
that
this was i had a new start i had a new
beginning
you know which is always great to know
that you have a [__]
i'm sorry about my eye i got one eye
that's up here or one that's like here
i'm like a junior cyclops
i don't know if i put too much visine in
one growing up i don't know what the
[__] is going on my eye
but i noticed that the other day in one
of the videos
when in between me going out on bail
and me getting sentenced from december
of 87
to august of 88 i did feel
the karma being served everything
a lot of bad [__] happened to me my
house got robbed
i got arrested i got arrested for
shoplifting
um i [__] ripped my arm open i needed
a bunch of stitches in my arm
i never got the stitches because i'm a
[__] but i ripped my arm open the
story's endless
i was just it was just karma being
[__] served you know
and uh there's things i think about
today and i go what am i gonna
pay for that thing that i did back then
you know i mean
at least i'm on that this is why a
couple weeks ago i did a podcast and
after i did the podcast
i was mad because you know so what some
kids steal some [__] videos from me
you know i'm gonna be mad and do a
podcast and yell on a podcast
that's [__] hypocrisy joe for years
you stole videos like a [__]
i didn't steal videos but you know by
the time i was stealing
videos weren't none to steal i didn't
steal no videos but you understand my
point that
i'm a hypocrite because i got pissed
because some kid was stealing videos
for years i stole everything that wasn't
super glued down
and all of a sudden i'm mad you know so
i felt that
that those nine months karma was being
served i did pay for a lot of my sins a
lot of [__]
a lot of skeletons that i had in the
closet came out
you know like little personal issues
that nobody really knows about that we
all know about ourselves
that we can't control came out you know
i felt it being served
you know but it's so weird also when
you serve up karma it's it's it just
feels great
when somebody has [__] with you or
somebody has wronged you
or somebody has done something to you in
the past and you take the high road
you take the high road but still karma's
still going even if you take the
listen when it comes to somebody messing
with you or somebody doing something
wrong to you
like the things i did to people all that
all those years
there's no there's no high road you know
there's no
you could either take the low road and
keep being a [__] jerk off or be a
high road and apologize
what i'm trying to explain that
[Music]
there's no [__] you know when you're
waiting for karma to get served
there's no high road i expect the worst
you expect the [__] worst you know
uh last week i told you about when the
girl fell off the bike and [__] like
that
i still think about what if what if my
daughter falls off the bike
is that going to be karma served for
that so do you understand me
i have a lot coming to me i've done a
lot of good things and i've helped a lot
of people
that i wasn't supposed to help i've
helped them out of the kindness in my
heart
they got kind of even out the game a
little bit to even out my comment but
i'm definitely
a big time believe in karma and even
when you don't want to serve it there's
times
you serve it like this times you might
have a misunderstanding with somebody
and you didn't take it that wrong but
the people around you took it wrong
and years later you get the opportunity
to [__] stab the dude or whatever
i was thinking about this this story
here that i was telling you about a guy
a couple weeks ago called jim wheeler
that when i got out
of bail he got married and there were
people
at his that were going to his wedding
that didn't want me at his wedding
so they didn't come and he sent them the
gift back
jim wheeler was my dog jim wheeler noah
was a wild man jim wheeler and joe rogan
are basically a lot of the same person
the way they treated me with jim wheeler
he knew i was a wild man and he knew
that i was gonna
be crazy but he respected my car sales
ability
he respected what i did my hard work he
respected me when i worked when i
when i went to sell cars i [__]
worked i went out down a lot i wrote
letters i made phone calls
i followed through my day was a lot
different than a lot of other guys
even though i was a [__] junkie and
when it came to comedy listen i'm a
[__] criminal
joe rogers never even got been arrested
joe rogan has never been
inside of a prison joe rogue is never
inside inside of a county jail inside of
a cell
joe rogers never done cocaine joe rogers
never done a drug
you ask yourself why does a guy like joe
well why would somebody like jim wheeler
hang out with me because they have
respect for
how i you know held myself up
in comedy you know with joe was calmly
me and joe have the same
mentality towards comedy it's all a
[__] nothing
you got to commit you got to write you
got to get out there every night there's
no [__] excuses
and that's it that's how you get my
respect when it comes to comics
you know with jim wheeler he liked me
because you know he
whatever you know when you're when
you're in the car business you move
around a lot
stores go hot stores go cold pay plans
a new general manager comes into a store
and he changes things around the life of
his car dealers
they move around like every six nine
months every once in a while they catch
a break
for three or four years on a nice
dealership but they move around my man
big joe
over in st louis you know ma joey fulato
he you know he moves around every two
years sometimes he's doing f and i which
is finance
sometimes he's just a closer it just
depends what type of deal they close
it's not that they're bad people that
they're moving around they're going to
support a family and jimmy wheeler's
case
you know he had two kids then supported
family so
he got me that job to start this story
off
we got to talk about jim wheeler he's
the one that gave me the job in the
subaru place
after i got out of prison i didn't sell
a car the whole month of december and he
had to let me go
but throughout that he always had a job
for me
okay jim wheeler always had a job for me
so forget about jim wheeler
forget about joe rogan i'm going to take
you to october of 83.
i was living in snowmass village and i'm
living my roommate is jimmy burkle god
bless his soul
and at night three four nights a week
the only
i was 20 at the time so i didn't turn 21
till
so i really couldn't go to bars in
colorado when i first got there yeah i
looked older
and i had fake ids and stuff and i snuck
into bars
but i didn't want to go to bars i didn't
want to go all the way up to aspen and
there was a couple of bars of snowmass
that you'd go to but during the week
we kept it light we went to this hotel
called the crestwood
the crestwood had the coolest [__]
staff at the time
plus they had a section for employee
housing where all the employees lived
and it was just a [__] party
couples couple girls couple guys
always a great time the leader of that
whole [__] click
up there was a guy by the name was vince
hall
he's dead now rest in peace great guy
from north carolina
he was must have been about 40. to me i
was 20.
he was just an old [__] man but i
respected him
i liked him he was he was into fishing a
lot of fishing
so he'd go fishing five six days a week
and he cooked fish on the grill for us
and it was me
and they in 83 i didn't work that in 83
i worked
around snow mass and i would go to the
crestwood at night the employee housing
was on the corner of there was at the
end all the way at the end of all the
condos
they had like their own maybe two floors
and they had a jacuzzi outside of that
that condo and we had like a little
gated area and then we had a yard back
there
i mean it was all wilderness back there
was a ski resort back there what am i
saying
so we hung out out there a couple nights
a week we'd meet
by the jacuzzi at seven we just jacuzzi
bring up a couple joints bring up a few
beers and just [__] you know
we were all in our 20s 21 there was a
couple clicks
there were a couple of us there was 10
dudes from like monroe louisiana
one dude worked there so his friends all
worked
hung out with him and there was some
other dudes from mankato in minneapolis
they were bad ass [__] they
lived 17
to an apartment there was 17 of them in
a two-bedroom apartment in my building
in the deep
in creekside apartments in d building
they lived on the third floor
they all had jobs and they all just
lived and met and they all lived in an
apartment just to ski because they
they were never there they all had two
jobs they all worked on the ski
on the slope in the morning and then the
night they'd work at a restaurant
or retail or everything was about skiing
everything was about skiing with those
guys and jumping off cliffs and mountain
diving and
and [__] going you know when you raft
in the summer these guys were [__]
cool the dudes from mankato
one of their guys worked for a rafting
company so if you were bored you go
rafting on saturdays on the [__] arm
and the other guys they [__] i mean
they were just
great guys they were just they they also
worked
for a [__] uh all the other ski
resorts so we all had passes
from different mountains it was just
great being 20 up there
but during the week it was us me carl
this guy kip he had a friend from chico
california
you know there was no girls that hung
out with us i could lie to you and tell
you there was [__] there was no
[__]
it was just like six or seven guys there
was maybe some of the girls that worked
at the hotel
vince me carl and these guys and we
would go there and talk [__] and we
would go home by 9
30 it would get cold and we go then
there was another group of guys that
were like 25's
to 26's and that guy's name was doug and
he hanged out with a guy mikey
and they had another guy i forget what
his name was he was like a viking
looking [__] and [__] like that
and they were okay with us and then
there was another crew that worked at
the hotel
and they were between 28 and 32. i
remember one of them
i forget what his name was like steve
but i still remember being in a closed
room with him
he was like an adult i'm [__] 25 i'm
21.
he's a [__] adult we're all 21 year
olds and he's like
i wonder what van halen is going to
sound like with
sammy hagar i'm so excited about that
i'm like you're 29 years old what are
you excited about
you're a [__] old man what can you
imagine i'm like telling him like oh man
now i'm 58 i'm [__] twice his [__]
age
and i'm telling him you're a [__] old
man you should be out doing [__]
worrying about sammy hagar what the [__]
is wrong but he was a good guy
he was one of the dudes that i went to
uh to denver with when we rented the
plane it was me
cato carl and this guy that said
they used to always say set the urban
free
that's all the dude would say he was a
white dude and every time you'd see him
he'd say
let's set the herb man free so he hung
out on that crew too
and they were all nice guys we were all
very nice i swear he is
there was never a problem in the four
months i lived up there
i would go up i didn't even drink and i
would chip in for beers you know
never a problem everybody liked each
other i liked the louisiana guys
i liked the guys from mankato i love
will
uh [__] whatever
the [__] hall brothers kip and his
buddy from china we were all tight
one saturday night i remember this like
it was yesterday but i remember the
story i remember the story the other day
because i was just thinking about karma
being served
and how our lives work out one saturday
afternoon
we're sitting there i don't know what we
all did
and we all met up there about six
o'clock and we're just hanging out
having a good time talking [__]
basketball
or whatever whatever 20 20 year olds do
and a car pulled up and it was this guy
doug
and another white dude but at that time
was employee housing
so there must have been 15 people in the
house
and like eight of us and nine of us
outside
and doug and his [__] friend whatever
his name was they still know what the
guy looked like
get out of the car you know they were
too cool for school
they walked past us and went into the
[__] house
so we had like a tub like those metal
tubs and
and every night whatever you showed up
with they just put in the tub
and then carl will get ice from the
[__] ice machines
and we just cover it up whatever was in
there wine coolers beers whatever the
[__] they had in there
some nights there was 50 beers some
nights that was 80 beers
some knife they were six beers so on
this particular night there's like
[__] 50 beers
it's like six of us hanging out talking
[__] doing bong heads
you know my feet are in the [__]
jacuzzi maybe
and doug and his buddy come out and
they're like hey guys how you guys doing
and they were they used to hang out at a
bar called the woody creek tavern
they were like two dirt merchants you
know like we didn't hang out at those
i used to go to woody creek just to get
we with my buddy cato
i forget what his last name is cato
that's what we used to call him
i forget what his real name was but his
street name was cato so
these two guys come over and it starts
off fine we're talking they drink their
beers
they say can we take another one carl's
goes go ahead man help yourself
they take another one and then i don't
know where they go all right we're gonna
leave
and the guy like the guy that was with
doug kind of like said we're gonna leave
now anyway
and he spit like i don't know it didn't
come off right
and then he took two beers gave them to
doug
and he took two beers and as they were
walking away carl goes
oh where you going with those [__]
beers man you didn't even ask for him
and the guy turned around he goes hey
[__] redneck man
i don't have to ask for [__] beers
you know
i'm just taking them i thought they were
there he goes now but i'm telling you
to put them down and the guy goes well
since she said it like that
i'm not gonna put them down now i knew i
didn't know what everybody's ability was
in there
i knew i was a little nuts i knew the
one guy from new orleans
had broken some guy's arm like a month
earlier
and aspen he was like a judo guy and he
just broke the guy's [__] elbow threw
him up
so i knew the judo guy was a badass
[__] i knew nothing about carl
carl was six foot one lanky big hands
big knuckles but carl was nuts like
anyone who said something
no he's the one he's the one that said
hey bring back the [__] beers where
the [__] you guys think you're going
and the guy was like very disrespectful
he's like what the [__] is your problem
redneck boy
or some [__] he goes i'm taking the
[__] beers and carl looks back and he
goes
i'm telling you put them down
put them down and the guy goes i ain't
putting [__] down
he goes i'm only going to put them down
to knock you the [__] out or something
like that
and car goes you want a [__] prime
[__] so half of us get out of
the tub
vince his brother comes out and goes
what's going on i go
you know so we we all go over the guy's
got the two bottles in his hand
and he's like what you really want a
problem and carl goes
i'm going to tell you to put the bottles
down again the guy goes i'm telling you
i'm taking these with me he didn't even
say whip me
and call through a punch that i had only
heard
once before that was that loud dog he
hit him so hard
that when the guy's face turned whatever
he had here
hit the floor like three feet away he
busted his [__] head with his hands
guys
i mean there was just an explosion of
[__] blood
the guy went down like tom segura
remember how tom segura landed on his
arm and [__]
the guy the punches went pop and the guy
just went
boom and he's [__] just dropped hit
his head
and then carl took the beers out of his
hands i told you you were gonna put the
beers down
and he took the two beers out of his
hand and he goes doug put the [__]
beers down
and doug goes i'm gonna put these beers
down but what you did
you weren't right what you did he goes
what what did i do he goes the guy
threatened me and i stuck up to myself
and that's when his brother goes yeah
doug i think he got the wrong [__]
bunch of guys here tonight
you know i saw the whole thing go down
he threatened my brother and he called
him a [__] redneck and all this [__]
put the [__] beers down and doug goes
we'll see how tough you [__]
are
i'll get yours back so we don't we laugh
at it
the [__] they got bro they had one of
the [__] uh
tourists had to come down and put a
turban around the guy who said the guy
was bleeding profusely
they had to pick him up into the [__]
car and we all went in the tub like we
don't know nothing
cops came like a half hour but later and
they asked what happened
like we have no idea the guy must have
been drunk when he fell from skiing
nobody do nothing now it was a saturday
sundays was our big day
sundays we used to [__] meet at the
snowmass
uh there was a snowmass club
there was it was like a big [__] gym
that i was a part of when i was a
volunteer fireman
i think i told you about that story on
the church you're gonna go into it
but you could they had a big huge
property even though i was a volunteer
fireman i don't remember that
let's not get into that
so every sunday we would meet at like
oh 10 maybe 9 30 me and the new orleans
boys the mankato boys
carl can't it was a bunch of us
and we play two-hand touch football
hand touched that's it real gentlemen
everybody had a good time and then we'd
go by the
uh new orleans boys and they would make
like a gumbo
or they would [__] fry catfish up
this is this was just a dream
i was just a kid out of jersey i had
never been to colorado i had never had
friends like this before
but every [__] weekend we did the
same [__] once friday came
friday night we all went to the same and
there was no cocaine involved
you didn't hear me say nothing about
coke i wasn't doing
these i was doing coke but
these guys didn't know i was a thief and
then i snorted coke by myself
these were just great guys and we were
all young
and we're all just having a good time so
on sundays we play [__] two-hand
touch football
and we got so good at it that we became
a team
and then we would play like the guy from
the conical gas station from old
snowmass
we were playing some guys from basalt we
were playing some guys from [__]
aspen
you know from a restaurant so it'd be
like snowmass so this went all the way
up to uh we started doing this like in
august and we went all the way up to i
think in november it got too cold it
started snowing
but every sunday we'd do this and then
sometimes after we played football
we would just go into the back with
trucks and go shooting
everybody had guns you know the the
mankato boys were hunters
they would hunt deer and the new orleans
got they were they weren't from new
orleans they were from monroe
louisiana i'll never forget these
[__]
and they were into shooting so sometimes
we would play football take our guns
afterward
and go in behind snowmass like there was
just
acres and acres that you could drive in
deserted roads and we just set up
targets and all of us would shoot
shotguns and he would let me shoot his
shotgun
i would shoot his double barrel he would
let me shoot like whatever so it was
pretty interesting
it was just a bunch of young guys and we
were having a [__] blast
nobody was fighting there was no sex
nobody was [__] nobody else was
girlfriends it was just
kids having a good time and then this
[__] saturday night this
happens with this [__] jerk off all
right
so we forget all about it we get up the
next day we play football
and we go shooting so we got our guns
with us but instead of going back to
louisiana that day
we were getting fish and we were going
to grill them on the on the grill
up by the crestwood by the employee
housing and we're all going to hang out
over there
we didn't even you know i think it was
mentioned one time about what happened
the night before
that [__] uh call had knocked out
doug's friend
nobody really got into it so all set by
the jacuzzi
we got guns in our bags you know my guns
like the car like i was i was with
somebody else who had a car
i like to say it was my road buck but
i'm not sure
and all of a sudden four cars pull up
and it's doug the dude with the [__]
turban that
that car had knocked out the reason why
i said he went down like tom segura is
because
he had a broken arm too he landed on his
elbow or something happened
but he got a broken arm he came he got
out of the car he didn't have nothing
the guy but doug and all his friends had
sticks and [__]
[__] sticks and [__] and [__]
they're like we're gonna [__] yours all
up blah blah blah blah blah and then
vince came out and we had like 10 people
in the house
all the new orleans kids were there and
half of the mankato ones were there
so we all just rose and we go you want
to [__] fight [__]
we'll [__] fight and vince goes i
don't know what this is about
all i know is that last night i
witnessed you try to bully my brother
and then my brother knocked you the [__]
out [__] you up
and now you got the balls to come back
here and start more [__] problems
well look what we have here do you
really want to [__] do this
or do you just want to bang it out well
the one guy goes well i'm his brother
and i just want to crack at your [__]
brother and
call goes [__] it let's do it i don't
give a [__] if you're as older his
younger brother i don't give a [__]
i'll knock out i'll knock you out the
same way i knocked out your [__]
brother
i'm sitting there going holy [__] and we
got guns too they don't know we got guns
but the new orleans boys
they weren't scared of [__] pulling
their pistols so i'm like this is gonna
get [__] ugly
the guy comes out carl gets out of the
[__] jacuzzi
they wrestle for a little while carl
gets on top and pounds him like 10 times
we pick him up it's all over but the
shot right
so when all this was going down i was
kind of yelling like i'm like this ain't
gonna happen
i go what should happen here doug doug
doug was out of line
i was never too crazy about doug let's
get this out of the way
i like doug and you know like doug was
one of those guys that he just
he was an acquaintance but when
everything was going down they were
going to beat carl up you're not going
to hit carl in front of me
and i got vocal with doug i go doug you
got some [__] pair of balls
coming up here with these [__] guys
that's disrespectful this is our [__]
thing here
you came up here last night started
trouble and now you're gonna come back
today and start more [__] trouble
doug
and he's like you know what man maybe we
should put our [__] gloves on i never
liked the yankees too much anyway
and i'm like let's [__] do it [__]
you know and before we got down they
broke us up
and the [__] no we're gonna be cool
car had already beat the kid up
so vince kept saying to him you already
got beat up
what's next we beat up your grandfather
you know like like you already got beat
up
you know so take him in the [__] car
and get the [__] out of here
a little argument it was like 20 minutes
argument and we all went our separate
ways but doug kept saying
yo new york i'm gonna be looking for you
and i kept saying
whenever you want to [__] right you
know and i was a little scared
he had me by five years you know
whatever i'd never been in that position
i'm a little scared i go home i don't
think about it
december comes january comes i come to
new york
i [__] end up homeless i'm here 18
months
i go to [__] boulder i'm in boulder
in 85
i'm i head up in san francisco and now
finally november of 86.
this is three years from the time
with the [__] karma i go back up to
snowmass village
i hook up with vince and carl and i'm
hooking up with the boys and we're doing
our thing
and one day out of the blue i go hey
guys
what the [__] have happened to doug and
they're like
doug you mean shotgun doug and i don't
know
doug the guy that came up that day and
carl
smacked his friend around they're like
you have no idea what happened with this
[__] idiot
he's getting high with a girl one night
they're doing coke at a hotel in snow
mess
and he was i never got high with him but
supposedly he was one of those creepy
guys when you got high with him i never
got high with him at all
like i said at that time i was doing
coke i just wasn't doing coke with them
nobody really in my circle knew i did
coke i kept it a secret so i could rob
everybody so they would never think it
was me
so i go yeah doug i guess that's what
they call them shotgun doug the one that
[__] call
knocked his friend down he goes oh that
[__] was doing coke with a girl
one night
and for you fact checkers that you find
everything please find this
find this and post it when i did the uh
the ryan sickle podcast
i told the story about the guy that shot
the four kids and somebody found the
article for me in boulder
and the michael bell article please find
this article
about shotgun doug snowmass village 85
so he's getting high with a girl all
right the girl gets up goes to the
bathroom
or he got up and went to the bathroom
when he came back he said there was more
coke there than what there was
it was like five in the morning and he's
like all coked up and he's like man
there was more coke here before i went
to the bathroom and she was like i don't
know what you're talking about
you know we've been just to a coke and
he's like there was more [__] coke
there
you better [__] get the coke out or
i'm gonna [__] kill you
and the girl's like what are you talking
about i didn't take your coke the guy
goes in the back room comes out with a
shotgun
puts it to the [__] girl's head and
he's like give me the [__] coke back
you [__] [__] i'm gonna [__]
shoot you well somebody was walking by
and seeing all this going on they dialed
9-1-1 and squats around at this [__]
house
and he had the girl at gunpoint like
give me more coke
or i'll shoot the [__] girl like
that's what he was asking for this is no
joke people
this is a true story he hurled he held
the girl
captain until they brought him more coke
this is [__] insane
he kept yelling that the girl took his
coke and
finally they [__] made them put a
shotgun down
they arrested them and nobody knew what
happened to him
including me i don't know what happened
to him so what year is this guys that
i'm
telling you about 80 [__] five okay
right there 86 right there i forget all
about shotgun duck
all right but i i always knew i wanted
to smack him in the face
i didn't like that yankee remark and i
never heard that before
i had never heard somebody call me a
[__] yankee so i was like that
[__] called me a yankee
i gotta get him back so i asked people
what happened like
he's probably in jail he's probably dead
and buried by now but there's a thing
called karma
and karma never [__] forgets that's
why i love you [__] that think
you get away with [__] you don't get
away with nothing i'm 58
and i've seen [__] unwind like i've seen
people like mike come up to me and say
joey we got to go beat up this [__]
dude he did this to me and i'll go
don't give it a month or two watch what
this guy gets himself into on his own
and sure enough he gets [__] stabbed
and you're like how did you know
because you knew the direction he was
going and i've seen it a thousand times
i've seen it a thousand times you don't
have to [__] you don't have to call
out everybody who crosses you
because eventually they're gonna [__]
themselves up and then you can laugh in
their face
and then you could [__] send them
that tweet and go go [__] your mother
now
whatever you know that's why you got to
be careful when you rub [__] in people's
faces you got to be
real so i'm not thinking
nothing about doug nothing my life is
going on
we're gonna take you back to 1994.
i did time i uh
got into comedy and
i went back to jersey uh
93 and i tried to get my life together
after the divorce
and i tried to do some comedy i got a
job limo running you guys have heard the
story
now i'm back and um i go back october of
93 november
93 i go back to boulder colorado
i want to be a dad i want to be a
[__]
father uh i moved to avada first i got a
job at like douglas toyota
but i wanted to move to boulder i'm not
a denver guy i'm a boulder guy
at the time i don't know what boulder's
like now this is at the time
so i finally get a [__] apartment in
boulder
and i'm hustling i'm trying to make ends
meet
and december comes along and boom i get
a [__]
somebody's telling me that jim wheeler's
looking for me so i go really
i call jim wheeler back this guy always
had a job for me
he calls me he goes joey i got a [__]
perfect job for you
no suits no ties we're gonna work at a
car lot named sprinkler
sprinkler car lot and longmont colorado
because i told the guy all about you i
told him that you could speak spanish
he's going to give you a 5 000 advance
a 5 000 bonus and he's gonna give you a
demo
to come work here and your hours are
gonna be ten to six
six days a week i go
this is the perfect [__] comedy job
it's not even in boulder it's a long
month
between you and i guys at that time i
wasn't very
proud of going to prison
so i kept it under the hat i felt very
out of
place um i had been out of prison four
years
and i still hadn't told unless you knew
me
i wasn't very open about that
conversation
i kept that kind of i was very
embarrassed at the time about it
and i had every right to be i'm still
embarrassed about it
but i i did something with my life so
it's not as embarrassing as it was back
then
when you first come out of prison i know
for me i was very embarrassed about it
and i wasn't as open as i am today about
talking about anything
i didn't say [__] to anybody about it
when
jim wheeler called me i go jim is he
gonna check for felonies and he goes nah
don't worry about nothing i'm gonna get
your license
you're gonna be fine because you need a
license to sell cars only
you know not only a driver's license but
you also need a sales license
and sometimes you can't get it if you
have a felony
so he goes don't worry about the license
i got you so
boom i got the [__] sprinkler finally
you know i'm gonna get some [__]
financial help you know i mean i was
making ends meet
but this car this job would put me in
the you know four to six
seven thousand a month range and i could
really do comedy and really you know
like this will really help me i still
got my knights to myself
this job meant the world to me i [__]
went there
elbows and [__] brother you know me
dog
i just don't talk to talk i walk the
walk i sold four cars in four days
i made like 2 000 [__] bucks
first week i think i made 2800 bucks
second week i think i made like 2 400
bucks on cars
i mean this was a great job it was easy
it was for people that kind of had bad
credit so they paid a little extra
financing
and you made money on the financing it
was going to be a perfect job
it was already like december 15th and i
had made five thousand bucks
and i was gonna go off and this is it
this is gonna be my sales job
i got myself a sales job i got my comedy
career going
everything's going on track
finally sprinkler decides to have a
christmas party
december 18th december 17th one of those
days we're gonna have a christmas party
we're gonna sell cars till three and
then from three to seven he's gonna have
to spread out
food the whole [__] thing i get there
everybody got t-shirts on i think i sell
a car
and all sudden we close down and we're
about to have a party
and it's still cool out it's still you
know 60 degrees
it's colorado it's 60 degrees in fact
it's so cool out we're playing
basketball
we're playing basketball all of a sudden
you know more people kept coming you
know like the sprinklers party more
people kept coming
it's 1993.
who's at the [__] party who looks at
me and goes you remember me man i go
yeah shotgun duck
and he looks at me and he goes hey man
don't call me [__] shotgun
and i go all right i won't say nothing
so now we're playing basketball and
we're covering each other
right i'm covering him he's covering me
i'm pretty [__] good in basketball
even though i'm by this time i'm 30
something i'm not fat i still got a few
moves and [__]
[Music]
i'm taking him to the hoop i'm out
rebounding him he's making little
comments
he's saying oh you got good playing
learning how to play ball in prison
bro my blood pressure went up 2
000 over 2 000. so i started calling him
a shotgun doug
shotgun doug shotgun what's the story
and he's like don't call me shotgun
i go well then check your [__] words
too and he looks at me he goes like i
say whatever the [__] i want
i go remember 10 years ago when you said
that the car hole
and your buddy's head almost flew off
his [__] shoulders
and he's like that was done but this is
now and all this [__] we're playing
basketball
and i'm like i can't lose his [__]
job i can't say nothing to this kid
because i can't lose the job but now the
guy that owned the [__] place
whatever his name is is outside also and
he's watching we're playing three on
three
and he's watching us playing this
[__] game papa
and finally guy goes yeah joey got
really good in prison
and dog i was never so [__]
embarrassed in my life
i waited and also everybody goes having
game is over all right let's go inside
and eat
and we all got dressed and [__] and you
know it's just your regular car lot
with like a trailer you ever see like
they all have a trailer like a
a metal trailer and [__]
you know wheeler's my boss jim's there
you know and i love jim to death
and we're all talking or eating i don't
know pizza whatever mexican
food and i'm so [__] pissed at
shotgun doug
because he ratted me out he told
everybody i'd been to prison
i was so [__] embarrassed plus i
still owed him a smack to the face
from [__] 83 in the [__] crestwood
that day
that's right look at him like doug you
want to smoke a giant [__]
he looks at me kind of weird but he's a
stupid [__]
me not knowing me knowing i went to
prison
and whatever knowing what we had just
gone through i wouldn't have smoked a
joint with me
but he agreed he goes yeah i go let's go
around the box
old man sprinkler don't see us i get him
around the back i go
you ever say anything to anybody about
me going to prison again he goes [__]
you
i grabbed him by his ears like i grabbed
the dude in prison
who had the long hair dirty hair i
grabbed him by the [__] back that he
is and i pounded his head against that
[__] that [__] trailer like 20 times
until [__] sprinkler came running out
with jim wheeler
jim wheeler grabbed me off him sprinkler
grabbed me off him
shotgun doug was crying he was [__]
crying
i go yeah i don't call it you know you
were [__]
telling people i went to prison i was
you know i told you not to tell people
how does it feel now [__] and
he's like well [__] you
you were calling me shotgun i'm like but
i didn't mean it like that i just
thought that's what they called you i
didn't mean it like that
but you know what man as i was walking
away like i looked at him
and i'm like you know what [__] this
punk
karma just got served
i got fired the [__] guy came up and
said you can't raise your hand there on
my lot
i'm gonna have to fire you he's like
good friends with me and i told him i
said bro
it was just a misunderstanding there was
no customers
we you know he didn't know who he was
talking to
it took me [__] 10 years because i
was still mad at him from that night
when he called me a [__] yankee
i had never heard that expression before
i'm like what the [__] is a yankee i
never heard that before
like we don't like you [__] yankees
so it took me 10
[__] years almost to the date it was
like 10 years and two months
from the time he called me [__]
yankee to the time i banged his head off
the trail i lost my job
they paid me i didn't go to jail why was
he
how did he get involved he was in the
car business
he had when he got out of prison he got
listen the car business when you
when you when you go to prison and you
get out of jail and you
you really are a human being like you
really need to work
the car business is nine out of ten the
only place that'll take you you can make
a hundred grand
cooks yeah he was making he was working
for a wholesaler
since we sold cars retail he was working
and that's how he ended up in this
[__] party but it's a small [__]
world brother
that's why you never know that's why
don't get pissed
be patient and you never know they call
dumbo
yeah now they call him whatever doug
[__] poor
dog i banged his head like 20 times off
that [__] wall
that's when i was [__] buck wild too
anyway
that's my story about karma and that's
uncle joey's joint tuesday
january 27th listen we made another
[__] month man
that's all i'm happy about january's
done
january's behind us next time i'll see
you guys is february [__] first
i love you [__] have a great
weekend and now
for a word from my [__]
sponsors stay black
all right thank you for listening and
taking the time out to hang out with me
and [__]
the [__] month is almost over but
we're here
we're here like the [__] mailman i
deliver no matter what
the joint is brought to you by blue
chew listen this [__] pandemic got
people down
and half the people don't even know why
they're down they're sexually frustrated
you got to go out and get yourself a
little piece you got to go out and
[__] swipe to the left
and meet a nice girl and when you do you
got to show up and make sure all the
goods are in place right or wrong
you can't show up with a dick that's
three quarters you haven't performed in
a [__] year
so that's where blue chew comes in uncle
joey's got you covered with the joint
the joint is brought to you by blue chew
why because it's [__] tremendous
you're gonna show up you're going to
show up and take that dick up
that's the stimulus check all these
freaks been waiting on nobody wants to
have a dead dick even me at 58
sometimes it's up sometimes it's down i
got to pop a blue chew and it works
tremendously quickly
effectively no [__] side effects the
next day i'm at the gym working out
i'm not huffing and puffing it's the
same fda approved ingredients
as viagra and cialis and listen you're
going down to a liquor store
you're going to some [__] store and
buying [__] that's not going to help you
out
blue chew is prescribed online by
licensed physicians
so you don't have to go to the doctor's
office and wait online at a [__]
pharmacy like a mooc
it gets shipped right to your house
discreet in the pouch nobody knows what
it is
it's between you and you even the
[__] mailman don't know what it
what's in there
and blue chew is cheaper than a pharmacy
and you could take them any time
day and night even on a full stomach you
could sling dick in the daytime sling
dig at night and it's all you blue chew
right now they got a special offer for
for the family
visit bluetooth.com that's
bluebluechew.com
and get your first shipment free joey
what are you talking about it's the
first of the month to get
free you're only gonna pay five dollars
for shipping
okay and again that's blue like the
color of a [__] face
you ever giving somebody a stabbing with
some good dick when you were like 20
and they're like [__] passing out
like that that's how you're going to
show up with blue chew
is that the dick you want to give or you
want to give that same old dead dick
that you've been giving out
and you can't even get a fly to hang out
with you you know what i'm saying
get to bluetooth.com right now use code
joey and they're going to send it to you
they're going to send you the first
shipment for free just pay five dollars
to shipping
that's bluechew.com
joey the joint is also brought to you
one of my favorites
listen cleanliness is next to godliness
all right you want to hang out with
jesus you can't smell like 10 dead
[__]
arabs you got to show up with a [__]
good game and your ball sack has to be
tip top magoo
yeah the big game is february 7th the
super bowl you got tampa bay
against [__] kansas city but the real
super bowl is valentine's day
that's the super bowl that's where you
shows up with your [__] balls
and put them in somebody's mouth but
first you got to trim them first
you got to trim the cobwebs the spiders
it's been a [__]
cold pandemic so let my friends at
manscape
treat you with a package like the gift
that is
and give your ladies something to unwrap
besides getting stuck in all the [__]
pubes and cobwebs
and [__] malukia balls and the
leftover exhumed from your [__]
[__] trim your balls used to be scary
but with manscape it's you can [__]
do it with the lights out you know why
because
it's even got a little light in the
front another do you like to guide you
you could trim your balls in the [__]
dark you understand me
that's how easy it is with manscape you
grab your [__] dick
you shave around your [__] dick pole
because if you want the tree to look
bigger the grass around it has to be
trimmed
and then you get each nut individually
and you trim them nice
[Music]
nice smooth like a baby's ass
and you get it all with the performance
package that's the package i run with
right here the performance package comes
with a leather [__] bag that's
tremendous
all right plus you get the lawnmower 3.0
[__] the best hands down or anywhere
they got the advanced skin safe
technology
that you won't nick or snag your nuts at
plus they throw in a little crop
preserver here
to keep your [__] balls nice and
smelling tight
and to tighten them up you got the crap
[__] reviver
oh my god you ever look at your elbow
you're like what the [__] is that then
you look at your nut sack it looks like
an elbow
only 10 times worse without the scab
that's what my nut sack looks like
you put a little crop revive on that
[__] tip top magoo
it looks like a man's bald [__] head
i got two bald heads
between my leg why because i [__] with
manscape.com
joey that's why get the complete package
why [__] around
and they got a new cologne that's
[__] tremendous so your neck will
smell good
your dick will smell good your balls
will smell good everybody's smelling
good
it's a good [__] festival all over
the place right now
manscape is giving you 20 off and free
shipping
at manscape.com joey you're like joey
what the [__] are you talking about
that's 20 off and free shipping at
manscape.com
joey who's better than uncle joey
[__] nobody
and this year i got the petition
february 13th
is international trim your nut sack
[__] day that's it
get the [__] card from hallmark go to
manscape.com right now
press and joey and get 20 off of the
package the ultimate [__] package
performance package which is [__]
tremendous
you understand me you got to be prepared
i want to thank manscape
i want to thank bluetube i want to thank
draftkings don't forget to look them up
this weekend
nba basketball college basketball
[__] hockey you got [__] on it
this week
tremendous shroom tech the protein
[__] chips now
and we also talking about cbd lion how
much they've helped me
with my [__] therapy i want to thank
all five of those companies
but most importantly i want to thank you
[__] for making uncle joey's
joint happen
have a great [__] weekend stay black
i'll see you [__] next week
whether here
or patreon that's it
take a hike
you